hello everyone and welcome to round one
of the 2018 bill chess festival the bill
chess festival is a six player double
round-robin that's taking place in Bill
in Switzerland hence the name the bill
chess festival and here we have a game
from round one it's Magnus Carlsen world
chess champion versus the Czech
Grandmaster David Navarro and it's
really a crazy game I'm sure you'll
enjoy it I know we're in the middle of
the Bobby Fischer series but as I said
if there will be an interesting game
from this event we're definitely gonna
check it out
so here we have a couple of nice photos
by Leonor totes let's check them out
these are the contenders of the bill
chess festival Magnus Carlsen Peter
Svidler Maxima Sheryl Grove a bit shy in
the back there we have a sugar mama dr
of taking this photo session very
seriously david Navarra clearly enjoying
himself and the local hero nico your
goddess so those are the contenders and
here you have a nice photo of world
champion Magnus Carlsen with some kids
at the bill chess festival so that being
said let's check out this very nice game
Carson had the white pieces and he
opened with d4 we have Knight to f6
Knight to f3 d5 C 4 and a 6 so transpose
it into the Queens gambit declined
Bishop to g5 we have Bishop to b4 check
blocking with Knight to c3 we transpose
into Dora goes in defense and now h6
checking to see eater Carlson will move
back the bishop let's say Bishop to d2
will he capture on f6 or maybe he will
go for the Queen to a four line Carlson
please but Bishop captures on f6 he
doesn't mind giving up the bishop pair
Queen captures and now III we have
castles rook to C one D captures on c4
Bishop captures on c4 and c5 and now a
very well very interesting decision
costs and plays a d captures on c5 i
which of course seems it could be a bit
dangerous let's say rook to d8 displayed
attacking Carlson's Queen but it's you
know it's both fine for white and black
after a Queen b3 bunch of characters on
c5 but there's no rule
for white here so instead nice the d7
navara simply keeps on developing he
will grab the c5 pawn with the night we
have castles Knight captures on c5 by
Navarra Knight the b5 and now comes a
six attacking Carlson's night
we have night beat d4 sorry about that
night beat the d4 also you could go
something like night to c7 attacking the
rook but I have to rope to b8 this
Knight really doesn't have all that much
to do here I mean it doesn't have any
retreat squares so it would it would be
pointless to do this so after a 6 we
have Knight B to d4 b5 now attacking
Carlson's Bishop Bishop back to e2 and
now II five a nice central thrust making
room for this light square bishop of his
that still undeveloped on c8 here
Carlson has to make a pretty big
decision the night it doesn't have all
that many squares if he goes something
like Knight to b3 then rook to d8 will
be very dangerous for white after white
moves the Queen let's say Queen to c2
Bishop to f5 will trap Constance queen
as you can see another as Bishop is
slicing all the way here the lights were
but should be slicing all the way here
the rook is controlling the entire D
file and of course the pawn is nicely
guarding the c-4 square so this would be
winning for navara so here cousin had a
different plan he played a knight to c2
which also allows Nevada Nevada to trap
his Queen Navarro does play rook to d8
and this is the moment where it all
happens
Carlson doesn't really have a choice
here but he willingly went into this he
must capture on before and allow rook
after sandy won the Queen has nowhere to
go and you cannot block the rooks attack
towards the Queen so Knight capture some
before we have rook captures on d1 rook
captures on d1 and now as Nora's knight
on d5 is attacked you could move it 97
Navarro goes for a 5 so if course and
captures Navarro will capture night on
before first crossing plays knife to d6
and here we have Queen to d6 you have to
defend the c5 Knight of course you can't
defend it with something like Queen the
c6 because then 90
and check will win the Queen so after 95
we have Queen to d6 defending and now
comes Knight captures on e5 a very nice
move by Carlsen if Queen captures then
rook captures on c5 this will be very
nice for white instead and Navarre goes
for Bishop to b7 attacking the knight on
d5 we have Bishop to f3 rook to c8 and
now comes Knight to g4 getting the
knight out of out of harm's way as the
Queen was attacking it and here it seems
like navara can once again do something
very nicely
f5 would trap Carlson's night here but
if f5 okay the knife has nowhere to go
but the knight doesn't need to go
anywhere
Knight d2 f6 and you open up a
discovered attack to the Queen the black
king is in check black loses the Queen
and the game either you move the King
and then rook captures queen or you give
up the Queen for two nights but you know
it's not all that great because you even
lose the Bishop Bishop captures and you
cannot recapture because of rook
captures rook this comes with check and
it's a completely winning position for
white so after Knight to g4 we have
Queen back to f8 and now cousin plays h4
so what you do here we have Knight to d7
Navarre offers a trade of rooks Carlsen
accepts rook captures and now Bishop
captures of course not Queen captures
then 97 would again check the King and
win the Queen Bishop captures on c8 and
now a 3 we have h5 attacking Carlsen's
night-night back to H 2 G 6 and now
Bishop to e2 attacking the pawn on d5
and here for some reason and navara
doesn't doesn't defend the pawn he could
either push it with something like
before or he could try and defend it
with the Queen to c5 rather he tries
nice to e5 he wants to go for for some
activity and and attack cousins King so
Carson grabs the pawn bishop capture
some b5 and although this seems like
like a totally meaningless thing I mean
you're the one with the Queen what's
what's one little pawn on the Queen side
but as you'll see you know it's not all
all black and white Bishop to b7 we have
Knight to c3
and now Queen to e7 rope to d4 Queen to
e6 and now knife to f1 car cousin has to
remain over denied to bring it back into
the game
Queen to b3 attacking the B to pawn
cross and defends it rook to d2 and now
Knight to c4 navara is forcing exchanges
so now either you will capture on c4 and
then Navarro will capture the bishop
Carlsen rider goes for rook to d7 and
okay nice capture some b2 we have rook
captures on b7 and now Queen captures on
c3 as the knight is no longer guarded by
the pawn we have Bush rook to e8
attacking the f7 pawn of course you
cannot defend this so King to f8 at
least the check the grab of the pawn
will not come with check
Bishop captures on f7 and now Queen to
c6 attacking Carlson's rook so you do
have to capture on b2 rope capture so we
have King capture some on f7 and now
rook to d2 so now it's a it's a rook and
the night against the Queen but also
cousin is up two points so it's black
should still be better but it's you know
a queen by herself can't really do all
that much and what Carson will do of
course you will try to create a caste or
rugby for push the pawn to a4 so the
rook will be guarding everything from
there and you know that that's what he
wants to do first SATs first and then
see what he's able to do so first
Navarro goes for it
Queen to a4 attacks the opponent the h4
point as you can to defend both cross
and decides rope to d3 it's better to
attack the a3 pawn and give up the h4
pawn because you don't want to allow the
bar to create a passed pawn on the Queen
side so Queen captures on h4 we have
worked the d7 check King moves and now
look back to before attacking the Queen
Queen e7 and now comes a for Queen to a3
we have g3 Queen to a-1 tries to pin the
night we have kingi to g4 comes nice to
d2 and now g4 so as you can see now
these all the pieces and pawns are
ideally placed across and plays Knight
to e4 and now you can see that there's
no real way for the screen to do
anything the pawns are regarded nicely
the Knight is guarding the f2 pawn
regarding the night also da for pawn
this nice III point is guarding the rook
so there is nothing black can actually
do to break through here so what you
should do is play King g7 and not allow
this Knight to f6 check to pick up this
pawn but for some reason it seems like
navara well of course he knows this is a
draw there's nothing you can do here but
for some reason he played Queen to c1
probably thought that it's you know just
just all the same so here across simple
simple played Knight to f6 check King to
f7 and now he grabbed a pawn on the King
side and okay it seems like the position
didn't change all that much it's just
one pawn on the King side or is it we
have Queen to c6 check King to g1 and
now Queen to c1 check King to h2 of
course Coulson doesn't want to allow a
repetition of moves as now cross and you
know his appetite has grown larger he
wants to go here for something more than
than just half a point here King to g6
we have Knight to f4 check King to f5 f6
and now Knight the g2 we have King to g2
g 5 and now rook to f4 and well it still
seems like there's really nothing white
can do here but what cousin has done
Carson completely restricted Navarre
scheme never asking can not only use the
G file in the H file the knight will
definitely find a nice place after this
pawn is pushed to e4 so after this point
is pushed to be for the night will come
to e3 and then look for something to do
but what Carson was able to do here is
create a nice pass a pawn and now he
wants to start pushing it so Queen to d1
now if course and pushes it pushes the
pawn to e4 then Navarro will capture the
a for pawn so first night to h4 what to
do you have to play something there's a
really not all that much you can do with
the King if you move the King to h6
you're gonna you're gonna lose this
point not not immediately but you know
the Queen has to also do something
either
this check is coming and then you're
gonna lose this pawn
so maybe maybe just cause and we'll
start pushing his past upon you do have
to play something with black and it's
not all that clear
perhaps King to h6 would would have been
the best but here Queen to c2 was played
here we have Knight to f5 Queen to d3
and now e4 and Navarro allows calls and
to start pushing his passport Queen to
d7
we have East East a5 Queen to h7 check
King to g1 and now Queen to g6 Carlson
plays Knight to d6 which is definitely
the best move you you will start of
course pushing your past pawn very soon
rook to a5 check is coming and the idea
that the night belongs and e6 is is the
following if Queen b1 check then King
can move to g2 because now Queen b7
check is impossible the Knight is
guarding it of course if you would move
the King to the H file then Queen would
go back to h7 to check the king but
after King G - there's nothing to do
here
Queen has to go back and now after 94
check King would move you would continue
pushing your passport and with even with
this defense which appears to be the
best white with the white would still
probably be winning with the best a pawn
but after Knight to d6 and Navarro
played Queen ecigs and here Carlson was
able to simply play rope to f5 check and
there is nothing to do here anymore
King gauge 6-volt King h6 and g6 fold
the rope to f6 check which loses the
queen sonhwa I simply decided to give up
the Queen this way Queen captures we
have Knight captures keen captures and
here crossing simply plate f4 across and
is off two points of course this is a
completely winning endgame for white
never replace G captures on f3 we have
King to have to King captures on e5 and
now King captures on f3 2 points against
1 1 is under quick links' everyone is on
the Queen side of course this is
completely winning for white King to f5
was played and now crossing simply
played King to e3
of course no no further explanation is
needed here but you know after King
attacks this pawn this King will simply
grab this point and this point will then
march
his way to victory so yeah a nice game
from round 1 and you know I I didn't
think it was possible to actually win
this game but as usual somehow Carlsen
manages to squeeze water out of stone
so as for some other results
I believe chakra dear mama D Arif was
able to defeat the local hero Nick oh
yeah this Carson has defeated David
Navarro here in this game and Peter
Svidler has drawn his game against
Maxine vascular graft so that's round 1
of the bill chess festival in
Switzerland a very nice game definitely
you know a worthy of round one and
someone mentioned somewhere on Twitter
that Carson never wins the first game he
plays in a tournament or he that he
hasn't for a couple of years but this
year he already won two games in round
one that he has played so definitely an
improvement and definitely a nice boost
to his rating Carson started this
tournament with 2000 I believe it's a
twenty eight hundred and forty eight so
this brings him over twenty eight
hundred fifty
so we'll see we'll see how it goes
definitely gonna be an interesting
little tournament so that's that's it
for this game I do hope you enjoyed it
navara most likely didn't as it was a
completely drawn game but somehow Carson
always finds a way so as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon
continuing the Bobby Fischer series but
perhaps again with another nice game
from the bill chess festival thank you
all and I'll see you soon